[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
treizième numéro tout de suite le
sommaire de ce jeudi 13 décembre la
commanderie fait son tout premier noël
décalé depuis le samedi 8 décembre de
drôles de sa part entend donc investi la
chapelle ce week-end les festivités
s'intensifie nous sommes allés faire un
tour
le club de handball de saint-cyr-l'ecole
fontenay le fleury organise son tournoi
de noël dimanche 16 décembre une
rencontre sportive solidaire qui
soutient une association dans une
ambiance festive et déguisés vanessa du
métier sera avec nous pour nous le
présenter et depuis 25 ans les archers
de guyancourt proposent leur tournoi
annuel
il aura lieu ce week-end des 15 et 16
décembre 203 marchés sont déjà inscrits
[Musique]
la section loisirs du club de handball
de saint-cyr-l'ecole fontenay le fleury
fête noël un noël sportifs bien entendu
mais aussi solidaires avec nous en
plateau vanessa du métier aux morts
alors vous occuper de la section loisirs
du club
c'est la huitième édition de ce thon à
noël ça devient un vrai rendez vous pour
le club
oui c'est un vrai rendez-vous un rendez
vous important qu'on organise juste
avant les fêtes de noël pour passer un
bon moment ensemble effectivement tourné
vers la solidarité avec une association
qu'on met en valeur alors justement
cette association elle change tous les
ans parce que c'est un noël ces retours
noël généreux
donc cette année c'est laquelle cette
année on a décidé de mettre à l'honneur
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque qui en tout
cas finances des opérations pour des
enfants
qui sont élevés dans des pays où
malheureusement ils n'ont pas la
possibilité d'organiser ces opérations
là aussi tout un volet formation des
médecins et puis également du parrainage
scolaire donc on avait vraiment souhaité
en tout cas pouvoir mettre à l'honneur
l'ensemble de leurs actions tournées
autour d'eux des enfants 6 à 6 ans une
association qui existe depuis 96 et déjà
3000 enfants qui ont été opérées en
france donc c'était important pour vous
de l'aider à continuer cette oeuvre
voilà toujours mettre en valeur
l'ensemble des actions qui sont portées
par par l'association c'est un petit peu
l'idée que l'on souhaite faire en tout
cas pour chaque édition avec des thèmes
différents on a pu avoir les chiens
guides aveugles par le passé de paris où
également une association de lutte
contre la sclérose en plaques voilà donc
l'idée c'est toujours de mettre à
l'honneur et participez en tout cas à
une action portée par sa part une
association donc tout ça autour d'un
tournoi qui a une petite particularité
il est déguisé avec un thème la dernière
c'était les jeux vidéo je croise assez
cette année cette année on sera au tour
des groupes de musique
voilà donc le déguisement retenu pour
pour la section loisirs de saint cyr
l'école sera les viets schiphol donc
voilà on invite tout le monde à venir se
déguiser et c'est quelque chose qui en
général l'ensemble des équipes jouent
vraiment jeu elles sont vraiment partant
donc voilà ça bon moment un bon tournoi
mais ça vous parle plus un peu sport et
à ses équipes qui sont déjà inscrits
elles vont s'affronter de toute la
journée de 10h à 18h et ses équipes qui
sont mixtes toujours des équipes mixées
le principe du loisir en tout cas
d'échec du championnat loisir donc une
partie championnat sur toute la journée
avec des matchs de quinze minutes
et puis en fin de journée des matches de
classement pour déterminer en tout cas
qui sera l'heureux vainqueur de cette
édition il ya un vainqueur qui est mis à
l'honneur
c'est ça donc devant vous il ya un
ballon et pourquoi ce ballon avec un
logo spécial parce qu'en fait le
tournant est labellisé hambaly sim pour
promouvoir l'euro féminin qui organisait
cette année en france voilà donc le
tournoi a été labellisé en val ici dans
le cas de cette grande opération liée à
l'euro féminin organisé en france cette
année
donc notre tournoi se déroulera dimanche
le jour de la finale finale à laquelle
on espère que la france sera de nouveau
et voilà donc du coup on a obtenu le
label qui effectivement sur sur le
ballon et qui est le gagnant du tournoi
ça rappelle la belle finale le tournoi
et demi que j'ai vu qu'il fallait
toujours du fil dans le shaq est
toujours une fille dans chaque équipe
sur le terrain
et effectivement l'ensemble des équipes
jouent vraiment je donc pour récolter un
maximum veut organiser en plus de temps
dans une buvette une tombola et un
tournoi de penalty il faut venir
nombreux en famille
voilà donc on invite vraiment l'ensemble
des participants à venir soient
accompagnés et puis tous ceux qui
veulent venir en tout cas passer une
bonne une bonne journée avec nous c'est
vraiment un moment sympathique tournait
vraiment autour de la solidarité et puis
il ya un ensemble de petites actions de
sensibilisation sur l'association qui
sont organisés et puis voilà il ya
vraiment tout cas nous l'idée c'est de
pouvoir participer et de données
un petit peu une contribution en tout
cas l'association qui est mise en valeur
ce jour-là vous attendez du monde
on attend beaucoup de monde et on invite
vraiment tout le monde à venir pas si ça
tourne avec nous dimanche alors que
justement ça se passe dimanche 6
décembre de 10 heures à 18 heures au
gymnase gérard philipe
vous pouvez retrouver toutes les infos
sur la page facebook de l'événement
merci jeunesse a du métier d'être venu
et sur notre plateau et non c'est vrai
alors merci beaucoup
on continue dans la compétition sportive
les archers de guyancourt renouvellent
leur concours annuel de tir à l'arc en
salle 26 cibles seront installés au
gymnase maurice baquet c'est samedi 15
et dimanche 16 décembre
230 archers se sont inscrits pour ce
tournoi qui est qualificatif pour les
championnats de france et se terminera
par des duels
l'accès est ouvert au public trois
participants sont au niveau
international l'occasion de voir des
pointures et de découvrir la discipline
ca pour moi qui l'ait prise est
justement parce qu'on organisait finale
par poule et qui permettent aux archers
qui sont qualifiés pour ces finales de
tirer au moins cinq duels
ce qui n'est pas le cas quand c'est ce
que son déplacement des duels par
élimination directe
et c'est toujours intéressant de voir
comment ça commence pas ça concours de
tir à l'arc et puis de voir aussi
comment les les participants peuvent
gérer leurs tirs notamment au niveau des
finales parce que les finales ça
représente un stress très important
alors si vous êtes archers vous pouvez
encore vous pré inscrire par mail
et si vous êtes simplement curieux le
gymnase est ouvert dès samedi midi
sortez vos pattes d'eph et vos vestes à
paillettes les chocs ce le club de
roller d'elancourt vous invite pour un
défi marathon de disco roller au profit
du téléthon
cela se déroule dimanche 16 décembre de
15 heures à 18 heures au gymnase
chastagner ce week-end vous pourrez vous
pouvez aussi retrouver du padel le club
de bois d'arcy organise ce samedi et
dimanche en tournois homologués hommes
et femmes à partir de 10 heures
les matches se disputeront en deux sets
gagnants l'occasion aussi de découvrir
ce sport tendance qui nous vient
d'amérique latine
la commanderie à elancourt propose la
première édition de son noël décalé et
solidaire il s'ouvrait le samedi 8
décembre avec une exposition et un
atelier
terme flottante auquel a participé
grégory canal est drôle de sapins et
drôle d'ange dix artistes ont revisité
ses traditionnelles décorations des
fêtes de fin d'année pour le noël décalé
de la commanderie
l'exposition entièrement composé de
matériaux de récupération s'est ouverte
samedi dans la chapelle
c'était un peu notre rôle de proposer un
noël différent à noël avec des artistes
anaëlle avec des amateurs noël avec
aussi des parents enfants puisque on a
aussi des propositions en famille
notamment un atelier lantern flottante
durant deux heures les enfants
apprennent à construire leurs lanternes
avant d'éteindre la lumière
on en a fait 12 des feuilles en tout et
on a on a on a quoi les tous puis on a
mis une pastille on a mis du polystyrène
en dessous et puis on a mis une bougie
des lanternes qu'ils pourront déposer
sur la pièce d'eau de la commanderie ce
samedi 15 décembre avec tous les
participants de l'atelier les enfants ça
super content en ça coûte vraiment pas
cher et puis voilà une construction qui
s'est fait à la main avec eux et pour
leur âge c'est magnifique
les festivités se poursuivent et
s'intensifient jusqu'au 16 décembre avec
des concerts des stands solidaire et
même des activités plus surprenante
nous aurons un sauna alors un sauna
mobile à la manière du bagne et à ruch
donc une petite caravane qui va être
placé à côté de la pièce d'eau de la
commanderie où vous pourrez venir faire
un vrai sauna entre amis
trois places possibles le noël décalé de
la commanderie présent jusque dans la
cour avec un arbre à mot auquel
participent chaque visiteur et vous
pouvez retrouver le programme complet du
week-end sur le site internet et noël
qui investit largement saint quentin en
yvelines ce week end pas moins de sept
communes organisent leur marché de noël
qui commence dès vendredi pour mort par
elancourt le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
de magny les hameaux se transformera en
jardin imaginaire avec même un manège
carré qui tourne rond et un feu
d'artifice à 18 heures samedi 15
décembre à guyancourt et la verrière les
marchés de noël seront solidaires et
portés par des associations
retrouvez tous les programmes sur les
sites de vos communes depuis le 1er
décembre et jusqu'au
19 la maison de covilha voisins le
bretonneux propose une exposition sur
les jeux vidéo des premières consoles de
1970 ça aujourd'hui elle retrace toute
l'histoire de ce qu'on appelle le
dixième art une fois incollables vous
pourrez même faire une petite partie sur
les consoles et c'est une nouveauté au
prisme des brunchs créatif le premier
aura lieu dimanche 16 décembre de 10h à
15h l'idée est de participer à un
atelier avec un artiste puis d'échanger
avec lui autour d'un petit déjeuner pour
cette première l'artiste clément d'azun
vous fera découvrir le jonglage
chorégraphique
vous pouvez encore vous inscrire par
téléphone ou par mail pour notre rendez
vous cinéma patrie jacques de dixmude
s'est rendu au grenier à sel à trappes
qui propose une soirée spéciale ciné
concert ce vendredi 14 décembre
[Musique]
vous retrouverez bientôt au grenier à
sel percute j'aime percute j'aime ça
sera vendredi 14 décembre à 20h45 c'est
la projection d'un documentaire sur le
groupe de musique perd plus de l'âme
musiciens exceptionnels il s'agit dans
les deux musiciens autiste qui viendront
sur scène après le film c'est un
partenariat avec la mairie des
réservations sont font sur le site de la
mûre is.com est le deuxième événement au
grenier à sel ce sera mardi 18 décembre
à 20h45 c'est le jean paul go qui
viendra progrès un tas d écart infime
sur un jeune marocain qui est convaincu
avec sa grand mère et qui vient en
france rencontrer des grands chefs
mais bien entendu il fera l'expérience
du travail précaire
l'expérience de l'immigration
clandestine
des micros et tout ça ce débat cette
rencontre se fera en partenariat avec le
mans a donc ce sera mardi 18 décembre à
20h45 pour grenier à sel c'est le canada
dans la vitre
un plaisir à tuer
le couscous au point perdre
tyson
[Musique]
on rallume la lumière pour notre
rubrique sortie en ile de france
[Musique]
direction la fondation edf dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris pour s'immerger
dans un labyrinthe de l'aide
l'artiste autrichien erwin raid à l'expo
son univers pour la première fois à
paris jusqu'au 3 février
reportage de nicolas le hérissé de nos
confrères la grand paris des milliers de
faisceaux lumineux est clair les 400 m²
de la fondation edf une installation
immense et immersive réalisée par un
artiste autrichien attiré par l'art
numérique les visiteurs sont invités à
pénétrer dans l'oeuvre et déambuler dans
ce labyrinthe de l'aide pour profiter
entièrement de l'oeuvre il faut entrer à
l'intérieur ce n'est pas seulement la
regarder de loin mais vraiment il faut
se promener dans l'installation prenez
temps qu'il faut pour observer tout cela
cela peut prendre cinq minutes ou 5
heures aussi pour cela je me suis
beaucoup inspiré des jeux électroniques
et de l'esthétisme des écrans
d'ordinateurs le public doit vraiment
exploré tout cela
[Musique]
installé sur les deux étages de la
fondation les lumières bleues et rouges
brouille notre perception de la
frontière entre le réel et le virtuel
piloté depuis un ordinateur les tons de
couleurs varient progressivement au fil
de notre visite des couleurs qui reflète
nos émotions
[Musique]
pourquoi ces deux couleurs le rouge et
le bleu ces deux couleurs marque le
début et la fin des différentes
tonalités existantes triplette hendry de
couleur représente la limite de ce que
nos yeux peuvent percevoir
elles sont aussi liées à nos émotions le
bleu est une couleur très rationnel
froide
vous voyez autour de moi tout est bleu
inverse le rouge
c'est l'opposé c'est une couleur
beaucoup plus chaude qui se rapporte aux
sensations et c'est cet aller retour
entre ces deux tonalités ces deux
extrêmes qui m'a plu est intéressé pour
cette exposition des sports
une exposition vraiment pas comme les
autres à découvrir sans plus attendre
jusqu'au 3 février
et c'est la fin de votre 7,8 loisirs
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous jeudi prochain pour le dernier
numéro de l'année
en attendant bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh